that our american profile of virginia
senator tim kaine
[Music]
this week on q a
author simon sebag montefiore he
discusses his book the romanovs about
the dynasty that ruled russia for over
300 years
[Music]
simon sivag montefiore the book is
called the romanovs
1613-1918 and i want to read you a
headline in the daily mail
london daily mail you wrote this back in
january
the red hot romanoff romance scandal of
the married czar and his 16 year old
mistress revealed in the raunchiest love
letters ever written by a head of state
i have to say i didn't actually write
that right that's the headline written
by the daily mail
headline writer
but
i would say that the correspondence
they're referring to is the most
outrageous and most explicit
correspondence ever written by a head of
state and i have to say the
correspondence is so outrageous that
they edited the daily mail the mail on
sunday in england rang me up and said
you know we're a tabloid newspaper in
england but we can't print all this
stuff we're a family newspaper who was
it who were who were who was the head of
state well the head of state was tsar
emperor alexander ii
the
emperor who liberated the serfs
uh the slaves of russia at exactly the
same time 1861
as your president lincoln was about to
liberate the slaves of america and the
two men were actually in correspondence
and both of them were assassinated
so
interesting interesting relationship
that for a start
and alexander ii was really the most uh
sympathetic of all the romanovs in this
book i think
and
he also um he also brought in jury
trials
and local electorate assemblies and so
he sort of laid some of the foundations
for reform he wanted to bring in a
constitution which was really the last
proper chance to bring it in but he was
assassinated the day he was going to
bring in that constitution
but as for the love life that's another
thing altogether um well let me ask you
first where did you find the love
letters well the love letters are in the
russian archives in moscow
but there's an interesting story there
because these love letters have never
really been worked on by any historians
before and that's because they've only
recently returned to the russian
archives and this is how it happened
when alexander ii was assassinated
his widow his mistress who'd become his
wife princess katya
left russia and went to live in paris
and she took most of this huge
correspondent 3 000 outrageous letters
with her to paris where they remained in
private hands until
1998 and in 1998
the rothschild banking family
bought these letters why because in 1945
the red army had captured when they took
berlin and vienna had captured the
rothschild banking archives and they
took them back to moscow and they wanted
to swap and the russians agreed
so the rothschild's got their banking
archives which aren't aren't very
interesting i'm sure
but
moscow got these letters and at last we
could work on them all and
their love letters between a
40-something-year-old emperor alexander
second and his young
school girl 18 year old mistress which
when they met and they started their
affair
they're passionate they're poignant
they're increasingly political
and they're highly uninhibited and
sexual in fact there's stuff in these
letters that i didn't even know
was invented in the 1870s i thought it
had only just been invented in the 21st
century but you'll have to read them to
see what i'm referring to so this
article that you wrote doesn't have all
the racy stuff in it it doesn't have all
the racy stuff in it because
because some of it is very racy even by
even by the standards of 2016.
how long was alexander the second the
emperor well he was he was emperor from
1855 to 1881
and how was he assassinated well
it was it was a tragedy he brought in
reform
um he believed in reform he negotiated
this complex emancipation of the serfs
so he'd shown real political skill
but he raised expectations in the 1860s
for for reform of autocracy which he was
not willing to fulfill
this caused a backlash that led to a
terrorist movement
demanding the destruction of autocracy
altogether and these terrorists hunted
him like a wild animal they threw bombs
at him they fired guns at him in fact he
believed because his mistress catcher
was there on the day of the first
assassination attempt he believed she
was his guardian angel and there were
six attempts to kill him but she
couldn't save him
when it came to 1881
after they'd been together for all these
years
that the bomb was thrown at his carriage
he
he was fine the carriage was she was
smashed but he got out and he inspected
the dead and wounded and his guard said
please get back in the carriage please
let's get you out of here. he said no i
want to inspect
you know this wounded man that's what i
do i'm an emperor and there was one more
terrorist one more killer and they just
threw the bomb right at his feet and
blew his legs to smithereens he was
taken back
to the winter palace where he died on
his couch
and one of the people who saw him die
was a little boy who became nicholas ii
his grandson
uh in reading your book and i just kept
asking how does this man remember all
this i i mean i probably could get in
here and find somewhere a statistic you
wouldn't remember but you certainly
would you could find a lot of that what
what technique do you use in order to
put all this together and and i want you
to eventually get into how many
romanoffs there were and all that yeah
well i mean writing these books is a
huge challenge and is a nightmare and
for some reason i have a taste for doing
these vast subjects like jerusalem over
5000 years this is only about 400 years
but it's 20 it's 20 or 21
romanov prince princes or or
zarzan's arenas empresses and emperors
emperors and it covers so many years
so you can imagine every single monarch
in this book
has their children their wives their
mistresses their ministers their field
marshals their great poets and composers
and
all of this has to be mastered so
writing these books is a hell of a
mental challenge i have to say and you
know
i literally immerse myself in the
subject um for the few years that i'm
doing and i only read about this subject
and obviously afterwards i can't wait to
read some sort of james elroy thrillers
or something you know the day i finish i
start reading sort of john le carre or
james elroy or something like that but
during it i concentrate absolutely on it
and i just work my way from the
beginning
rain by rain and with each one
i read all the books on the subject
first of all
um i get all the the books and
journals articles that have been
published in russia and then ultimately
i go to russia and walk around the
palaces look at the archives
and then when i feel i've got enough i
move on to the next
um to the next monarch
you were here last in 2004 and we also
did an interview peter slended in in
london in 2013. i want to just put up on
the screen the number of non-fiction
books you've written so that the
audience can know you know the kind of
thing you've been involved in we go back
to the first one in 2001 catherine and
the great uh catholic great and potemkin
yes stalin the court of the tsar which
we talked about in 2003 we did young
stalin 2007 jerusalem the biography in
2011. and we say the romanovs you say
romanovs well i mean it doesn't matter
but it yeah
i say both actually i mean the russians
say romanov you know but um
but we english say romanoff and we say
potemkin but they say pachom kim you
know it doesn't matter i want to you
mentioned rothschild the name wrong
child i want to quote back to you this
is a 2008 vanity fair article that
undoubtedly you remember
in which
a friend of yours is the honorable
hannah rothschild who is she
she's she's um she's a she's a novelist
and um writer and she's head of the
british the the british museum or the
the the she's she's a very important
woman in england and she's a daughter of
lord rothschild
and
she's a great person here's the quote
though yeah he is the best lunch date in
london his gossip is so clever ranging
through centuries and across all
sections of society did you find that to
be a compliment i don't know what do you
think i'm not sure i'm not sure if that
is a compliment but she's a great person
so you know she can get away with saying
this stuff are you a gossip um well you
know i think all human affairs all human
business all politics
is is about human relationships you can
call that gossip if you like i'm not
terribly interested in in gossip that
has no importance on the world on the
world stage but if you look at these
books for example in all of them
they are studies of power and how power
works its effect on personality and the
effect of personalities on power
i think the interesting thing is that um
even if you're whether you're talking
about a an imperial court with flunkies
and you know and chamberlains and and
ladies and waiting or whether you're
talking about the office of the
president of the united states or the
prime minister of england elected
officials
power works in a similar way
and it emanates from the person who's
been elected who has the power whether
it's obama or putin
and
i'm a student the way that works and i'm
fascinated by the way that that happens
so
i'm hoping that this book i mean you can
read it as an entertainment about a lot
of
shocking
murders and and the rest you can look at
it as an explanation about how russia
works today
or you could just look upon it as a
study of human nature and power
and you can call that gossip but really
it repeatedly shows i've just given you
one example you know in 1881 when
alexander ii was was murdered
his personality was essential to reform
going ahead
when he was assassinated reform really
ended in russia until 1917.
so
personality again and again and again in
russian history
just as in american history you know
look at putin look at look at trump look
at you know look at the clintons um
again and again personality is decisive
in power and in politics and so my books
concentrate on the personal who was your
favorite uh
personality not your favorite leader but
the one that you had the most fun
researching well peter the great is just
you know is just totally compelling
and you know he's a misunderstood
character and i wanted to look at him in
a very political sense as well as a
colorful character
when was he the emperor well he was
emperor until 17 17 1725 he died and
he'd been
um the emperor in 1682 since he was a
child so
an incredibly long reign i think what i
see what i find kind of breathtaking
with these people you look at you look
at some of the two of the greatest men
in this book um
peter the great and prince potemkin who
was catherine the great's partner
minister probably her secret husband
they had two of the most talented
individuals in in the whole romanov
story and yet both of them died at 52.
now i'm 50. so that's a pretty
terrifying statistic now there's a
statistic that i remember and that is on
my mind at the moment because think of
all they achieved in their years and
they died at 52 both of them utterly
exhausted by the way what did they
achieve why did peter would start with
peter the gray and why was he called the
great well he was called the great
because he achieved so much he he
modernized russia he brought in
modern military modern artillery modern
technology western experts
western forms of government and um he
modernized the military to the extent
that they could defeat the greatest
military power in europe of their day
sweden um he founded some petersburg a
new northern capital a modern city a
venice of the north
he conquered the baltic and he created
the blacks the baltic fleet the baltic
fleet which made russia
a naval path for the first time
and he did all of this really through
the force of his personality and despite
all the rational reasons and the
wonderful swedish methods of government
and the german titles he brought in it
caught and and the modern artillery that
he he he developed for the for the
military and these wonderful ships of
the line for his russian navy despite
all of this
modern stuff
he was always basically an autocrat who
ruled
wherever he was was the government
whatever he said was the government if
he slept the government slept
when he was drunk the government was
drunk he was everything and he was the
ultimate personal
ruler of russia
he was a genius but he was also a
monster you know he took he took part in
the beheadings of his of his enemies he
tortured his own son to death
um
he he you know he was fascinated with
the human body dismantling it um i
remember after when he was in um when he
was in holland and he attended all these
dissections his medical dissections he
was fascinated the human body afterwards
he queued up and he said can i bite the
body i want to see how the dead body
feels in your teeth and then he made his
entire entourage do the same and after
that he bought a he bought his own
collection of surgical tools and some of
his entourage had a sore tooth he
insisted on pulling it out himself
another one had a bad foot
off went the foot so after that if you
had a if you had a sore arm or a bad
tooth or a sore ear
and you were in peter the great's
entourage you made you made sure you
never mentioned it
how many different you said 21 or
something but how many different
emperors did you write about
um
there are 20
that are actually that actually ruled
but there are also many regents many
prime ministers uh many field marshals
there are many characters there are many
artists i mean this book has
everyone from tchaikovsky and pushkin to
dostoyevsky um
and it has you know many many
fascinating and talented people from
potemkin
one you know who was probably the most
talented minister that the romanovs ever
had um to rasputin who was probably one
of the least talented at least
politically least talented advisers the
romanovs ever had we talk about rasputin
for a minute
you go into great detail about him when
did he first pop up in
in the russian society well he first
popped up in 1905 and it's interesting
well i think the sort of analysis of him
in the past has been slightly skewed for
different ways too much emphasis on
whether he's a healer or not um the
hemophilia of of of zara [ __ ] alexi
and
what's much more important i think is
that he represented
um he represented what nicholas
alexandra felt was the authentic
foundation
of the romanov autocracy which was the
relationship between the tsar
and the peasantry do you recognize who
he's sitting with are he sitting and
who's standing behind him no i don't
recognize them but there he is
unmistakable
rasputin who was the first emperor he
had contact with well nicholas nicholas
the second
only necklace yeah it started with
nickel and and what was his relationship
with nicholas
well there was no love of that these are
great pictures um there's no love effect
there was no love affair as was rumored
um with alexandra but alexander and
nicholas both absolutely needed rasputin
first of all there was the healing of
the hemophiliac child a tragic story a
tragic family story and the parents were
were agonized by this by this by the
child suffering by his his pain as he
almost died repeatedly from hemophiliac
attacks
but also
by the immense stress they placed on
themselves by insisting that he must
succeed to the full plenitude of
autocracy
and
that the disease had to be a total
secret
so this placed enormous stress on the
child and on themselves and what years
nicholas ii and alex well night this is
1905 you know 1904 was when the child of
lexi was born they meet rasputin in 1905
the next year and he remains absolutely
key to them right up until his murder in
1916 in december 1916. i guess i didn't
ask the nicholas the second was the
emperor for how long time um oh over 20
years over 20 years 1894 to 1917. and
the reason i wanted to talk about
rashford this is the end of the romanovs
this is the end we started it so we're
sort of starting at the end but it's um
i mean it's an interesting
it's interesting you ask about rasputin
because rasputin became essential to the
to the parents as well as the child
but he didn't really become totally
politically important and essential
until world war one
and in world war one in 1915
nicholas decided to become supreme
commander in chief of the army and he
left the capital
in the charge of the empress alexandra
now the emperor's alexander was an
extremely prudish woman
extremely self-righteous religious who
believed absolutely in sacred autocracy
as a system and complete disdain for
democracy
and can i interrupt to ask you define
the word autocracy well talk which is
just the rule of one man
but sacred autocracy that is the romanov
ideology that russia could only be ruled
by one man the tsar of the legitimate
god-given god-blessed romanov dynasty
and
and when when nicholas ii left alexandra
in complete command of politics back
back back in in in petersburg or
petrograd it was then renamed
she found herself in this preposterous
situation having had for over 20 years
complete contempt
for all politics and high society and
politicians particularly in journalists
she suddenly found herself in the
business of politics
and she knew nobody
so she had to turn this self-righteous
very prudish woman had to turn to the
one person who she felt might know some
people in petersburg
and that was rasputin who only knew
the most incompetent corrupt and
depraved people in saint petersburg so
irony of ironies the people he sent her
and suggested as minister to her were
the most depraved and incompetent people
in in petersburg and this was a
catastrophe and this book is based on
many correspondences between between
czars and and and private
correspondences there's several thousand
letters between nicholas and alexander
at that time apart from being
fascinating because
you know they're very sexually
passionate about each other um they're
very close
it also reveals how isolated they were
isolated by their own wishes by the way
and how much they depended to an absurd
degree on rasputin and when you read
alexander's letters you realize that she
was close to being insane she was
unbalanced i mean the letters when you
if you if you when you read the book i
think people will be amazed just how
just how unstable she was and she'd be
sending nicholas things like rasputin's
comb to brush his hair before he met
ministers so he'd be blessed and
protected things like this so you
realize that that the prestige and the
power the monarchy is seeping away fast
when she's in charge who uh didn't like
rasputin
well no one liked rasputin except for
the imperial family of which there were
the children the daughter four daughters
and and the son
and the imperial couple
and by the by the time by the time world
war one started in 1914
um no one liked rasputin but people just
couldn't face the fact that the
responsibility for the misrule in russia
belonged to the tsar and zarina
particularly the czar
um
and they blamed it on rasputin they were
sure that if they killed rasputin they
would solve the problem of of russia's
misrule
how did they do it i i mean if you go to
saint petersburg and a lot of americans
do
uh where would they find nicholas and
alexandra living at that time and where
did rasputin live well nicholas
alexandra lived outside saint petersburg
they hated some petersburg they regarded
as a cesspit of immoral immoral
debauchery and they lived out at oscar
cello which was
a suburban palace and they lived in the
alexander palace the palace built by
catherine the great for her grandson
alexander the first bizarre of war and
peace we might come to him later but
where's the winter powers the winner
palace is right in the center of of of
um of some petersburg now rasputin lived
in a flat in the city and when he came
out to see the zanzarina it's ask ocelo
he would meet in a he would meet them in
a small cottage outside the city gates
that no one knew about that belonged to
a friend of theirs and that little house
is still there by the way and no one
goes to see it but they should because
that was where russia was in a way
governed
and it's just outside the gates they'd
come out because all the police and so
on controlled by the minister of the
interior will would make a record of
anyone visiting but anyway
this way they'd avoid anyone knowing but
of course everybody knew anyway
and
um
meanwhile also in the city there's the
yusuf palace which i'm sure many
american tourists would will visit and
that has the room where rasputin was
killed in the courtyard where he was
killed
and
prince yusupov was the wealthiest man in
russia he was a cross-dressing bisexual
opium addict
an interesting character who'd been at
oxford university of course
and um him and his friend um grand duke
dimitri was a member of the imperial
family they were both members of the
imperial family in fact and they decided
that the only way to save russia and
save the monarchy was to kill rasputin
they romanticized the killing of
rasputin in the ways that we all know so
that kind of rasputin was kind of
poisoned but he got up again he was shot
but he got up again you know virtually
like a vampire movie you know he was he
was they virtually claimed they suck a
stake in his heart and that finally
killed him but in fact
the murder was very different from that
and there were interesting things about
it one is we now know there was some
sort of british involvement the british
secret service
the early version of mi6
was involved somehow in plotting against
rasputin and may have actually been
involved in the assassination plot well
rasputin was widely believed first of
all to be against the war which was true
and that was i said that was that was
about the only sensible policy one of
the few sensible things he did devise
was stay out of the war but that was a
very difficult thing to to do to stay
out of the war
uh it wasn't something that nicholas ii
was really strong enough to withstand
the pressure to go into the war who's
which side was russia on russia was on
the allied side the american side the
british side the french side so
um
so they decided that they just the
british were interested in him being
killed one to keep to keep russia in the
war
and two to save the monarchy without the
monarchy russia would in any case
probably leave the war
and many people believe that the
monarchy would be destroyed if rasputin
continued his his dark influence
so somehow british agents who were
friends with yusupov
were involved in this plot and what
really happened was they layered him to
this house
they shot him once the bullet didn't
kill him he ran outside
and somebody from behind
fired at him and brought him down with a
second shot that was not fatal
and this is the interesting bit at this
point someone walked up with a huge
pistol like a sort of clint eastwood
style magnum
and they put it right against rasputin's
forehead here point blank
and just blew him away
like that you know it was it was not
this kind of romantic sort of gothic
um story that we we see in sort of
hollywood movies it was more like just
the cold-blooded execution of a peasant
here's the famous picture of rasputin on
the screen
what effect did this have on
and and what exact year was he killed
december 16. but you can see that um
this is a great picture this is where
he's he's actually they've dug that they
found the body underneath the ice in the
or the naval river they threw them in
there he threw him under the ice and
took a while to find him
and
what's interesting is you know he's
thawing there before his autopsy but you
can see that the the point-blank shot to
the middle of the forehead is an
execution shot and there you can see it
pretty clearly
so what impact did it have that they
killed him well the funny thing was it
didn't have the impact anyone expected
it instead of strengthening the monarchy
it exposed and emasculated the monarchy
because it revealed
that nothing changed when rasputin died
nicholas ii was still the same nicholas
ii ruling with alexander before
he didn't suddenly start reforming the
country or giving in to a constitutional
government or giving in to a
representative government nothing
changed all it showed was that the
government was hollow
and that nicholas ii was a deeply
incompetent ruler
i i'm at the end for a couple reasons
one
nicholas and alexander's
assassination and and the the fact that
the bolsheviks took over in 17 i want
you to kind of lead us up to that and
explain after this
assassination of uh rasputin
when when did the next step in this
process well i mean that was in december
1916 i mean the monarchy literally
lasted
two months afterwards
and
the irony was that you know this this
wasn't a revolution led by lenin and
stalin and trotsky they were all in
exile or in siberia in fact lenin had
said
just weeks before he said you know we've
missed it this revolution is never going
to happen in my lifetime
but
um but here it came it was totally
unexpected and yet easily predictable
because people started to protest about
food shortages in the capital and it's
quickly spread
um
the the troops who were in in the cities
started to fraternize with the with the
rebels
and nicholas was far away at the front
and he tried to where was he well he was
right at the front he was right at the
front at the headquarters
and it took him a long time to get back
and he was he was foolish to try to get
back in a rush because his train got
you know got sidelined supposedly
stopped by workers
and he found himself totally alone in a
railway station in the middle of nowhere
um and he had to ask his generals what
to do and the general said
as one abdicate
and so suddenly he was alone in this in
in his imperial carriage and he had to
sign an abdication so first of all he
abdicated to his son alexei the
tsarovich the hemophiliac boy
now in his teens
and then he spoke to his doctor and he
said just tell me something is this
hemophilia curable the doctor said no he
said is it
you know how long could he live he said
well he could live a long time but he he
could die at 30
he could die very young
and then and then he sort of said you
know what i've decided i'm going to
change change my plan i'm going to
change my abdication i'm going to leave
the throne to my brother michael
and keep this to keep the child with me
was that his decision it was that was
his decision any emperor could say this
is where it's going next well that's a
good question actually that's that's a
very interesting question one of the
great themes of this book out of modern
russian history and if we look at putin
is succession the succession in any
government
is a measure of its orderliness it's
it's
of its authority um
of its system if you like and you know
up until um tsar um paul the first
in 1796 any czar could just appoint
anyone who the hell they liked as their
successor so peter the great successor
was his wife catherine the first one of
the more extraordinary colorful female
characters in this book that's a great
she was careful in the first yeah
catherine the first but she was little
better than a sort of camp follower
she'd first appeared walking naked as a
as a prisoner into the russian camp she
was neither a russian
nor orthodox nor noble and yet peter the
great married her and made renamed her
catherine and crowned her empress of
russia when he died she was chosen as
his successor even though she had no
claim to the throne so in russia the
state can make the state can break
someone that that's the power of
autocracy so
so up until then you know czars could
choose their own successors but after
1796 no more the irony is that in in
nowadays
um
since the 1990s and in 2016
the presidents of russia who are again
autocrats
can choose their own successes again in
a way
that that is unthinkable really in the
21st century so you have president putin
was named by yeltsin as his successor
the election was it was was sort of
fixed and similarly you know putin chose
medvedev medvedev chose putin again
nominally so
once again we're in a situation in
russia where despite all the trappings
of democracy in the facade of democracy
again
the tsar can choose his own successor
but go back to why i mean the whole
revolution in 1917 and what happened to
the last romanoffs and yes well that's
just a terrible story
um
by the way i'm i i don't take the usual
romantic approach to nicholas and
alexandra that that
is traditional the movie view
um i don't take it um
and i and i differ from the sort of
traditional romantic approach they were
a couple who were in love with each
other they were um loving parents
but they were also rulers and i think
when people read in this book what they
were really like
um i think people will be amazed about
how rabidly anti-semitic they were for
example you know um
that that the the stuff about jews is
pretty shocking
um considering that they're regarded as
wonderful romantic heroes nicholas
alexandra and that connects to you and
your family well it connects to me my
family because we we left russia at that
time
my mother's family um to escape them but
also you know you know that that kind of
nicholas alexander's kind of
vindictiveness their duplicity i mean i
think people will be surprised when they
read the book
that
they may not recognize the nicholas and
alexandra that they thought they knew
and the family is only one part of it
but i will say that when they were
overthrown in in february 1917
they did conduct themselves with immense
grace in facing
fear humiliation
um of being prisoners of of a republican
government of a provisional government
and they then behave with immense
dignity and that's why they've been made
into saints by the russian orthodox
church but
at the same time as as um it's worth
remembering that at the same time as
nicholas ii
now abdicated now depose was reading
tolstoy and and books to his children in
in in in captivity he was also reading
his children um the protocols of the
elders of zion the the rabidly
anti-semitic um forgery so that made
this gives us
a little bit of perspective but you know
in the end when the bolsheviks took
power in october 1917 in lenin stalin
trotsky you know this was a totally new
turn of events suddenly they were in
danger of their lives
and it was unthinkable that the children
could be in danger of their lives too
but lenin and trotsky and stein were
ruthless ruthless operatives and they
could take no chances
it's clear when you look at it
that the orders
um to kill them all including the
children came from the top came from
lenin even though lenin was far too
clever to leave a written order he was
very aware of history but when it came
to kill them
um
to kill all of them these these four
gorgeous young daughters
the the innocent son as well as the
parents as well as the family doctor and
the entourage that was left
never has as a murder been so bungled
never has a crime been so
if it was possible to make it more
appalling and more atrocious
um
they did it by sheer incompetence and of
course where were they i mean you said
the scene where they were they were in a
house in the caleronberg the apative
house which had been renamed the house
of special purpose very sinister norman
name for the house and they were kept
there all the windows were painted white
um
and the family were sort of kept in
total isolation different members of
their entourage were taken away
mysteriously then shot in the woods and
gradually they realized that something
terrible was going to happen and yet the
white armies the armies opposed to the
revolution were approaching and they
could hear the guns at night
and the order came from moscow to the
akatarimbo to the urals um uh soviet
that if the whites got too near they
would they could wipe out the whole
family
and so this job was done
um they were woken up at about one in
the morning they came downstairs putting
on their clothes they were taken into
one room a cellar room and they just
thought they were being moved they
thought they were being moved um they
came down little boy sat down he'd
recently had a hemophiliac attack
princess empress alexander asked for a
seat she sat down nicholas stood in
front of the boy seemingly protective
and suddenly these sort of 12 rough
ruffians came in with with guns and
you know bayonets and pistols and rifles
and half of them were drunk some of them
were psychopaths who'd murdered people
before one of them had beheaded a man
during a bank robbery before the
revolution and they came in
and they read a sentence of death
and then they all started firing but it
all went wrong immediately because
everyone was supposed to kill one person
but of course a lot of them weren't
comfortable shooting girls so they they
aimed at the person they were meant to
shoot and then they suddenly switched
their gun and shot at nicholas ii in the
chest so he was killed instantly but
everyone else was screaming and all of
them were alive still and then there was
this kind of free-for-all of shooting a
fuselage off the fuselage
killing some of them but
tragically
all the girls and all the children
children basically were wearing
their own bizarre bulletproof vests
not bulletproof vests but vests sewn
with the romanov diamonds
hundreds and hundreds of diamonds have
been sewn into their underwear so they
could have money in case they escaped in
case they needed to buy their way out
and they'd spent months sowing these
diamonds in you know can you imagine
they had billions the equivalent of
billions of pounds on their bodies and
they weighed a for they weighed an
enormous amount but when the bullets
came tragically
um these these made their their
execution and their agony much much
longer because the bullets bounced off
diamonds the hardest substance known to
man and they didn't die so then they had
to go go in among the bodies the floor
um
as
they said like there's so much blood on
the floor it was as slippery as an ice
rink and they had to walk in and stab
them and shoot them in the head and
still two of the girls at the end of all
this after ended like half an hour of
mayhem terrible mayhem two of the girls
were still sort of coughing and awake
and had to be stabbed and shot all over
again i mean
writing it i i must admit i sort of wept
when i when i when i was when i was
writing this scene
um it's agony
how did who reported on what happened
and because you as i remember you talk
about being in a room with a dim light
bulb and you can't see each other and
all that and but who had the information
well the there's the interesting thing
is that all the um well several of the
um
of the assassins of the murderers wrote
proudly wrote memoirs about what they'd
what they'd done
and because the whole thing was such a
debacler and because it took literally
three days and three nights without
sleep to actually bury the bodies
because what happened with the bodies
afterwards which i don't think we should
go into now because it's so but it's you
know it involves sulfuric acid and fire
and petrol and fire and i mean and being
buried in different places and terrible
things being done to the bodies of the
girls especially and nicolas that um
that when they came to write their memos
they were so confused about what had
happened in this kind of three-day
sleepless three-day struggle to sort of
dispose to pose of the bodies that they
they contradicted themselves in
different places they're of different
versions
of the story and all of these were kept
in the archives and these are is this
new information that you found not all
of that no i mean there are new there
are new aspects of it yeah but um but
the story is still going on which is so
interesting because
as everyone knows the bodies were found
in the 90s and buried in 1998 boris
yeltsin super presiding and they were
buried in the in the in the family vault
in the peter and paul fortress in saint
petersburg but
um but two of the bodies were missing
not anastasia who did not survive
but grand duchess maria her sister and
the tsar which alexian their bodies were
never found and then 10 years later in
2007 so very recently
they found the remains of those two
bodies just just bits of skeleton and
they were tested by western specialists
and found to be the romanovs the missing
romanovs but the orthodox church
backed as always by the president of the
russian federation because in russia the
orthodox church is really a branch of
the autocracy
um challenged these findings and so for
ten years nothing was done with these
body parts then last year we're right up
to date now last year um
president putin his security agents
agencies and the church
suddenly decided they would test
everything again so they've exhumed
nicholas ii temporarily tested his body
they've exhumed the children and they've
tested these two last bodies
and as at the time of the time we're
speaking nothing's been announced yet
but i think this has something to do
with putin's view of history putin's
preparation for the centenary of 1917
and 1918
um the centenary which is coming up next
year and you're after
um
so
something is up with this i don't know
what it is but we're right there now so
the the
raman office and some in some senses
this story is happening right now as we
speak in russia
um something's about to happen and it
reflects president putin's view of
history and his view is very interesting
he
he is without ideology
he regards the two worst czars of russia
as gorbachev and nicholas ii for example
one is a soviet leader one is a romanov
tsar um he regards lenin as a disaster
for russia but he regards stalin as a
hugely successful statesman he regards
peter the great
alexander the first nicholas the first
is great catherine the great and
potemkin as great russian statesmen but
he regards nicholas the second as a as a
useless
flop who betrayed the country by
abdicating and he regards gorbachev our
great hero who will rest
as such an impressive liberal
um modernizer he regards him as a
disaster too
so he sees the empress of russia
apolitically
by he judges them by their success and
he sees himself president putin
as a russian leader a special russian
leader of the russian world um to be
judged with the great rulers of russian
history go back to um your comment about
anti-semitism
yeah and your own family and all that
i think i read in your linen and trotsky
who were on either side of uh stalin at
one point all were jewish no lenin
wasn't jewish not at all no jewish
some jewish some jewish um some jewish
something like a 16th jewish or
something he was um he was basically
rush and he also was part tata
um
stalin was georgian
and trotsky was jewish the reason i ask
you that is because throughout your book
there is a lot of anti-semitism over the
years what's that what's the basis of
that well this is the strange thing is
that you know the romanovs
let anti-semitism um become a family
fetish
that made no sense for them whatsoever
and this goes to us a wider wider crisis
in the monarchy that they had which was
that you know they couldn't quite decide
if they wanted to be emperor of this
huge multinational multi-religion empire
with all these
um different religions and faiths the
finns the poles the jews the georgians
the armenians and so on um the tartars
who were muslim
or if they wanted to be russian tsars
nationalistic um
of the sort of of the sla of the slavs
so this is a kind of one of the kind of
contradictions that they couldn't quite
work out and in the end
from nicholas the first onwards they
basically plumped for being
nationalist russian rulers
and they gradually and incredibly
foolishly alienated
all of their minorities none more so
than the poles the georgians
and the jews which is why so many of
those peoples became bolsheviks and
mensheviks and revolutionaries and
terrorists um
but they did it completely it was it was
a completely absurd concept they
regarded the jews nicholas ii used to
say
the british the brit the the englishman
is a yeared
by which he meant
that the english and the jews were the
same they they believed in all the
things that were wrong with the modern
world
um newspapers the stock exchange
democracy um everything that nicholas ii
hated and he regularly talked about just
once he said once he said someone said
him what do you what's a newspaper what
do you think happens in a newspaper and
he said a newspaper is just a bunch of
jews trying to make everyone go to war
with each other so he was rabidly auntie
there's a great scene when he goes and
stays with his cousins in england he
goes and stays with edward vii at
sandringham and adam vii was incredibly
pro-jewish and friends with the
rothschilds and other big jewish
families
and
um he had one of these big jewish
tycoons staying there baron hirsch who
was the wealthiest man in europe at the
time and he deliberately had him to sort
of try and introduce him to nicholas ii
to make him more pro-jewish and nicholas
ii was horrified and he wrote to his
mother he said they've got a lot of
jewish horse dealers staying here and
i'm so horrified that i think i'm just
going to not going to say a word the
whole weekend so that's what he did i
want to put the list of your books back
up on the screen
of all those books which one sold the
best
i think stalin called the reds are in
jerusalem are the two that have sold the
best i mean they're they're now in many
many languages i think they're in 45
languages now or something but from your
standpoint what's the thread through all
these books ah
um well the thread is simple they've
read just these are books that i longed
to write and i passionately wanted to
write i wanted to produce books on these
subjects that
were based on scholarship based on new
archives and yet were
readable by everybody um accessible so
if we saw you in an archive uh where
would that archive be physically well it
would either be in a kind of former
power palace in in moscow or in or in
the the archive the soviet archives
which is a special building 1920s
building in moscow or i might be walking
around as i might be walking around a
palace trying to work out um you know
where people where which actual rooms
they actually lived in or if it was
jerusalem i might be walking around the
city
tunnel going down the tunnels trying to
understand how how different layers of
the city were built on top of each other
the last time you were here in 2004 we
talked about the archives and you had
been in the archives of course for the
stalin book uh there was some inference
at that time that the archives were
going to be closed what's happened from
2004 to now in russia with archives well
there's been a huge sort of tightening
of i mean there's been a huge tightening
of access to the archives it's much
harder to work on them now especially
the modern ones i mean they don't care
so much about the romanov archives to be
honest but the stalin archives um and
any political archives are if they're
not open or they haven't already been
shown totally to the public they're not
going to open now probably
and
you know there's a real there's a real
dark atmosphere in russia at the moment
and this is part of an anti-western
xenophobic atmosphere and working in
those archives was never easy believe
you me
and i think i mean i remember the first
time i started working on catherine the
great in potemkin's archives the
archivists were determined that i
wouldn't find anything and when i
started working sitting underneath the
gallery and this arc of looking at the
documents for the first time the
archivist who tried to stop me went
upstairs and as i lent over the papers
there was a squealing sound
and something landed on my head and it
was a kitten
and i looked up at the i looked up at
the archivist and she just was leaning
over there and she just waved at me like
that she was just letting me know that i
wasn't that welcome in the archives how
many hours how many days have you spent
in those archives over there um i've
spent i've spent months over there
in those archives and but also like i
mean walking around places is also
hugely important you know in writing
these books because so often like when i
was writing about catherine the great
and potemkin you know potential villages
and villages that have villages that are
fake that have never been built
and book after book just said he never
built anything it was all a fake and
when i went down to the south to crimea
to ukraine to to sebastopol and so on
i found many of these um
you know many of these places had been
built by him and they're still there but
no way do you i mean when you're before
we talked about you've been to all 15
homes of uh
stalin yeah and have you been to all the
homes of all the romanovs yeah pretty
much how many oh i i don't know like
there are probably at least 15 palaces
probably more
you know there are so many of them
because every grand duke had their own
had their palace i haven't been to every
single one by far from it there were
thousands of them probably i mean if you
include all the hunting lodges not
thousands but probably um they're
probably up to 100 residences would
people let you in yeah they'd let you
they'd let us there did you have to have
a translator with you or can you now
speak good russian my russian is still a
work in progress but but you know
without it you couldn't do any of this
work and um you know you you can get
into all these places
and
and as for the letters themselves you
know there are many some of them in
russian but many of them are in english
i mean one of the one of the things that
may surprise people is that you know
everyone hated alex alexandra as the
german but actually she was really
english she was brought up by queen
victoria and she wrote you know her
letters between nicholas and alexandra
the love letters are all in english a
very sort of broken english but in
english
in english it's you know
time is running out and yeah this this
is has nothing to do with these books
but it does have something to do with
you i want to show your wife who has
written how many novels by now oh at
least 15. and you two live in kensington
and in london we do
uh and you've got fairly high social
uh presence over there i mean we
work a lot
but we've just written our first book
together oh yeah a children's book
that is um that is coming out in october
let me show your better half at the
moment her name is santa she's a lot
better looking than i am
here she is
my name is santa monty fury i live in
london here this is my garden in
kensington and i live with my husband
simon c by one fury and my two children
lily who is six and sasha my son who is
poor
i always wanted right i always did write
as a child i wrote little
books for
children and friends of my parents and
then when i got to school i started
writing short stories for my girlfriends
and then a friend of my mother's once
read one and she was a writer and said
oh darling you really should try and get
something published so i followed the
formula and i wrote one by return of
post it was sent back to me rejection of
course and that was the start of a lot
of rejections and i think being a writer
you just have to swallow the rejections
put them in a bottom drawer and continue
that's hilarious you two have been
married for you ever seen that no i've
never seen that but you'll notice when
she's leaning there in our library she's
it's quite funny because she's talking
about all her her lovely books that
she's written and she's leaning on
stalin's complete works just behind her
if you look carefully how long have you
been married oh god a long time i'm
married in 1998. how does it work with
the two of you both writing books all
the time you know originally we actually
worked at the same table when we started
writing we didn't have any hope that
we'd be successful so we had a very
small apartment
not in kensington and we had one table
which was also a dining room table and
our desk and we worked at different
sides of it and we spent our whole time
arguing about what kind of music to
listen to because she wanted to listen
to sort of celine dion
all the time which of course i could not
tolerate well i wanted to listen to sort
of guns and roses or david bowie or flow
rider or you know or or pitbull or sort
of loud driving music which helped me
keep up my narrative
drive in these in these long books so we
argued a lot about music we'll argue
mainly about music but now we have our
own offices in our house at different
ends of the house so she can listen to
all the celine dion she likes
as you know we haven't even
begun to talk about this book there's so
much more in here and there's one thing
i wanted to bring up because it just
stupefied me as i'm reading it the doors
the duals what's the whole i mean tell
us
how how often did these emperors
i don't know what you'd call it play
with the doors well the dwarfs are kind
of cute i mean a lot of reviewers have
said that this book reads makes makes
the game of thrones look like a look
like a vicar's tea party i think one of
them said in the financial times um
you know the dwarfs were kind of key
they partly signified the kind of
exceptionalism the sort of exceptional
sanctity of the tsar they wanted people
around them who they had a lot of
cripples around them a lot of freaks um
a lot of fools and they had dwarfs
and the dwarfs were were often like
their favorite people but peter the
great loved to have dwarfs weddings he
had giants weddings
the empress anna was really a character
out of game of thrones she was a cruel
horrible sultry
vindictive woman and she had an
entourage of women who were lacking
limbs so one was called the legless one
one was called the armless one she also
had fools she made princes into
into fools and they had to when she came
out of church they had to sit on eggs
dressed as chickens and cluck
um then she had a she had another fool
who she said should get married um and
so the fool invited to his house where
he was in bed
with a lachlan goat who he said was his
new wife and she loved that and worst of
all she loved dwarf tossing and dwarves
to have fights where they pulled each
other's hair and if they refused to
fight or refused to be tossed they were
beaten but if they did what she said
she would spoil them with new clothes
and food and big cash gifts so that some
of them became incredibly rich
by the end of by the end of the sort of
1740s but
it was an extraordinary story i mean
this is a this is an amazing sort of
family story if you think about it where
dwarfs are tossed
terrible cruelties are perpetrated the
empire is increased there are great love
affairs but it's also a family where
fathers kill their sons where wives have
their husbands overthrown and murdered
where sons collude in the murder of
fathers this is this is
a family unlike any other how many of
the 20 romanovs you write about were
assassinated or killed uh well of the
last 12
six were murdered violently or were
either assassinated or murdered so that
gives you an idea so from the sort of
from the late 18th century onwards half
of them were killed so i guess one of
the themes of the book is russia is a
very hard country to rule and to be czar
is a very hard thing to be
should president putin be called czar
putin
he should be because he's really the
tsar now um people say um you know is he
rich is he corrupt you know they're in a
lot of these stories um but russians
especially powerful russians that i know
just laughed about this about this very
question they said
for him wealth is irrelevant he's the
czar everything belongs to him
who did who tried the most to get a
democracy over there well i think
alexander ii
is the most kind of um sympathetic of
the family modern day um
you know of gorbachev
yeltsin is a hugely underrated character
i mean he was a flawed
flawed
great but flawed i mean he was a drunk
he went to war in chechnya and terrible
things were done there but he opened up
russia he tried to correct abuses he
opened up history um he brought in
democracy you say you brought in putin
what did he think putin would do
well the trouble with the russian this
is the six goes back to the succession
thing we were talking about earlier is
that it's impossible for an autocrat for
azar to retire without being murdered
and in our own period it's impossible
for a president to retire
without agreement that he in his entire
entourage and family will not be
prosecuted for either war crimes
or for vast corruption
and that means that in effect
it's virtually impossible for any
president to retire that's why when
yeltsin did retire he made a deal with
his successor and that's why putin can
never really retire and he was asked by
the way by his entourage will you ever
give up will you ever retire and he said
i could i'll never retire i will never
be like gorbachev or nicholas ii
and leave the country to chaos to scum
to hooligans he said they were weak
stars they were betrayers and i will
never abdicate i want uh those that have
joined us to know that in our c-span
archive they can find another three
hours of you talking about stalin and
jerusalem and other things
and uh this book the romanovs knew in
the year 2016.
what's next oh i'm going to write i've
written two novels
um set in set and said in russia in the
20th century their love stories and
their sort of thrillers and love stories
and i'm just writing the third of the
trilogy and then i'll have done the
trilogy which will be lovely next
non-fiction book ah well i'm not sure
about that i'm signed up to sign to
write a history of the world
which could be a step too far so
that's that's in the distant future what
do you do when you're not writing and
researching i spend time with my wife
who i love you i love you showing me
that video i mean that's that's a few
years old and it's so lovely to see her
but it's made my whole day it's cheered
me up enormously on this exhausting nine
city tour of america how old are you two
kids now they're now 15 and 13. either
one of them interested in writing yeah
they're both quite good at writing but i
don't want to pressure them because to
make a living as a writer is a very hard
thing and not many people
get to do it so i don't want to sort of
force them into doing any one thing or
other but
but it must be funny for them because
we're both me and santa are both writers
and as you can see she's kind of a
delightful person to live with
our guest has been simon sebek
monteviori his family is even in this
book i think on page 372 which people
can read called a book called the
romanovs
1613-1918 and we thank you very much for
joining us lovely to be here thanks for
having me
[Music]
so
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org q a programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]
if you like this q a interview here are
some others you might enjoy margaret
mcmillan on her book the war that ended
peace about the 194